Welcome to the deep Dive.
We take your sources, your
research, your notes, and we
boil them down, giving you the
key insights without you having
to wade through everything
yourself.
Today we're diving into
something pretty heavy, a topic
that for most people really
kicks off in February 2022.
You know, the images of Russian
tanks crossing into Ukraine and
the story we often hear,
especially in the West, paints
it as the sudden, almost random
act by Vladimir Putin.
He gets compared to, well, all
the usual suspects, Hitler,
Stalin, Mussolini, or sometimes,
maybe conveniently, he's painted
as this weak, dying leader.
But those portrayals, they often
clash, don't they?
It's a bit confusing, but maybe
that simple story is just
easier, easier to accept.
But that's not what we do here.
Our mission today is to peel
back those layers.
We got these fascinating, maybe
even challenging source excerpts
called How the West Lit the Fuse
in ukraine.pdf.
And just to be absolutely clear
upfront, we are not taking
sides.
We're not endorsing a political
view here.
Our job is to unpack what this
specific source says, to dig
into the history it presents.
We want to look hard at that
idea of an unprovoked war by
exploring while decades of
warnings and actions that the
source claims have been ignored
or maybe even deliberately
sidelined.
So this is about giving you, our
listener, a fuller, maybe more
complex picture of the history
behind this major global
conflict.
Exactly.
And the author of this material,
well, they don't mince words,
they flat out argue.
This conflict was, and I'm
quoting here, 1 long in the
making, nurtured by Western
arrogance, short sightedness and
a refusal to take Russia at its
word.
It's really strong language.
And again, our role here is just
to lay out their argument, how
they build their case using
specific events, specific
warnings.
It's not about US agreeing, but
about understanding their
perspective and some of the
points they raise, some of the
connections they make, might
genuinely surprise you.
They definitely challenge that
standard narrative.
OK, let's get into it then.
That common story, like we said,
starts the clock in February
2022.
But the source immediately hits
back saying quote history did
not begin in 2022.
That's not just semantics, is
it?
It's saying the real roots, the
seeds of this war, as they put
it, go way, way back.
Decades even.
Precisely.
And this is where the author
starts laying out this chain,
this pattern of warnings about
Russia's red lines, specifically
regarding NATO moving E.
The argument is these weren't
secret whispers, they were
explicit.
Russia stated them clearly,
repeatedly, and the West,
according to this source, just
consistently ignored them.
And they bring up some heavy
hitters to back this up.
Take George Canon for example.
Canon Yeah, the architect of
Cold War containment.
A huge figure in US foreign
policy.
The very same in 1997, as NATO
expansion was really getting
going, Canon warned publicly
that expanding NATO into Eastern
Europe would be quote the most
fateful error of American policy
in the entire post Cold War era.
Wow, from Canon himself that's
that's a heavy warning.
It really is coming from the guy
who basically wrote the playbook
for dealing with the Soviets,
The source argues.
That should have stopped
policymakers in their tracks,
but they claim it didn't.
OK, so that's Kenan in 97.
What else?
Fast forward about a decade to
2008.
You get this incredibly blunt
cable from William Burns, who
was the US ambassador in Moscow
at the time, later CIA director.
Of course.
Burns, right?
Highly respected.
And he sends this message back
to Washington, it apparently
said.
And this is direct language
here, yet means yet Ukraine's
accession is the brightest of
all red lines for the Russian
elite.
Yet means yet can't get much
clearer than that.
Exactly, the source emphasizes
this wasn't guesswork.
It was a clear signal about how
intensely Russia felt about
Ukraine joining NATO.
A non negotiable issue for.
Them So warnings from a Cold War
strategist, A top diplomat on
the ground.
And from Putin himself,
publicly, the source points to
the 2007 Munich Security
Conference.
Big international stage and
Putin gets up and as the source
puts it, declared, not
whispered, declared that NATO's
relentless eastward expansion
was unacceptable, a threat to
Russian security.
So he said it point blank to
Western leaders.
According to the source, yes.
Loud and clear.
No room for misunderstanding.
The message was out there.
OK, here's where it gets really
interesting then, because you
have Kenan, you have Burns, you
have Putin all saying whoa, hold
on with NATO expansion,
especially towards Ukraine.
But the source says the West
essentially quote ignored him,
meaning Putin, but also the
broader warnings for what,
nearly 3 decades?
That's the timeline they trace.
They point to the actual NATO
expansion that followed these
warnings.
Right, let's stick them off.
Poland, Czech Republic, Hungary
and 99.
Yep.
The first big wave into the old
Soviet sphere.
Then 2004.
That was huge.
The Baltics, Estonia, Latvia,
Lithuania plus Romania,
Bulgaria.
And the source stresses that at
every stage Russia protested,
they weren't happy.
They voiced security concerns.
But according to the author, at
every stage the West waved those
protests away as paranoia just
dismissed them.
So a pattern emerges.
Russia objects.
The West ignores or dismisses.
Exactly.
And this brings us to what the
source calls a really critical
moment, the 2008 Bucharest
Summit.
Bucharest.
What happened there?
Up till then, expansion had been
former Warsaw packed countries
mostly.
But in Bucharest, the official
NATO statement went further.
It said, quote, Ukraine and
Georgia will become members of
NATO.
Wow.
Not if, but will.
Precisely.
The source identifies this as
the moment Russia understood
that the West had no intention
of honoring its red line.
It was a public commitment to
bring these two former Soviet
republics right on Russia's
border into the alliance.
Even after Burns's net means yet
cable that same year, right?
And the source argues that
Western leaders then acted
surprised in 2014 when things
really kicked off after Ukraine
pivoted sharply away from
Moscow.
But Bucharest, in this view, set
that collision course.
It leads directly into 2014.
So if 2022 wasn't the start, and
2008 was this major turning
point in perception, then the
source says the real break came
not in 2022, but in 2014.
That's their core argument about
the timing of the rupture.
And they challenge how 2014 the
Maidan uprising was portrayed in
the West right, The idea of it
being just a spontaneous popular
revolution.
Very much so.
The standard narrative was, yes,
a spontaneous, organic
revolution of the Ukrainian
people, purely grassroots.
But the source claims what
Washington was involved.
It claims it was assisted,
shaped and in some ways
orchestrated by Washington.
That implies a much more active,
deliberate US role.
OK, that's a big claim.
What evidence does the source
offer for that?
Well, the most explosive piece
is probably that leaked phone
call Victoria Nuland.
This isn't Secretary of State at
the time.
The infamous Nuland call.
The very one she was apparently
caught on tape Conley
handpicking Ukraine's post
Yanukovych government saying
things like yachts.
Is the guy referring to Arsena
yachts.
And Yoku did become Prime
Minister right after.
And wasn't that the call where
she said something about the EU?
That's the one.
The source highlights the phrase
F the EU dismissing Brussels
role.
The author's interpretation is
stark.
This was not the language of
neutrality.
This was the voice of an empire
arranging its pieces on the
board.
Strong words, but it wasn't just
phone calls, right?
No, the source also points to
Senator John McCain physically
going to Kiev standing with
protesters in Maiden Square.
Very visible support for the
anti government movement.
And the source uses an analogy
there, doesn't it?
To sort of highlight the
perceived interference.
Yes, a deliberately provocative
one, they say.
Imagine a Russian senator on the
ground in Ferguson during the
Black Lives Matter protests.
Americans would have called it
foreign subversion, and they
would have been right.
Putting the shoe on the other
foot, it definitely makes you
think about how interventions
are perceived.
It forces you to consider that
perspective, yes, that this
wasn't just internal politics
from the viewpoint presented in
the source.
So what does this all add up to
this Western involvement?
And the source goes into the
money and politics side too,
right?
It does.
It talks about what it calls the
naked entanglement of political
power and private gain,
specifically mentioning Hunter
Biden joining the board of
Burisma, the Ukrainian energy
company.
Well, his.
Father Vice President Biden was
the point person on Ukraine
policy.
Exactly.
The source presents this as a
clear example of blurring lines
potential conflicts of interest.
And beyond that specific.
The source details how
organizations like USA and the
National Endowment for Democracy
Ned poured billions into Ukraine
since independence.
Billions for.
What?
According to the source for
Cultivating Ng OS media outlets
and political operatives, they
even mentioned Newland herself
boasting about $5 billion in US
assistance since 1991.
OK, so the source acknowledges
you could argue this was just
democracy building.
Right, they say you can debate
if it was benevolent democracy
building or covert influence,
but their conclusion is the
effect was undeniable.
Which was quote.
Ukraine's politics shifted
decisively westward with
Washington's hand on the scale.
Regardless of intent, the sheer
weight of involvement pushed
Ukraine towards the West.
And at Russia's perception of
all this?
For Moscow, the source says, the
message was crystal clear.
This was not an organic
revolution, it was regime change
dressed in popular protests.
Western backed coup essentially.
That's the perception the source
argues Russia had.
And that perception, that
conclusion, had immediate and
violent consequences inside
Ukraine.
Which brings us to the war
before the war.
Right, because the fallout from
Maidan in 2014 wasn't peace and
quiet, according to the source.
Start from it, they state.
Eastern Ukraine immediately
descended into civil war right
from 2014 onwards, a.
Civil War?
That's not how it was generally
framed leading up to 2022, no.
It often wasn't, but the source
describes how the Donbas region
declared independence right
after Maidan Keys response Kiev
sent in the army.
And the result.
Brutal fighting, shelling,
rocket fire and snipers
followed.
The source paints a picture of
an active deadly conflict zone
in eastern Ukraine for years.
And the human cost of that?
This is the part that's often
missing from the story.
It really is.
The source cites UN and OSCE
figures.
Those are official tallies,
estimating some 14,000 people
were killed between 2014 and
2021. 14,000 before February
2022 even happened. 14,000 dead
in those eight years.
It's a shocking number.
Which leads the source to argue.
That the war had already begun,
plain and simple.
By the time tanks rolled in
2022, the Don Boss had been a
battlefield for eight years.
So calling Feb 2022 the start is
misleading.
According to the source,
profoundly so.
Their conclusion is blunt.
To call February 2022 the start
of the war is to erase nearly a
decade of blood.
That reframing, that insistence
on the 20/14/2021 conflict, it
really does challenge the whole
unprovoked narrative, doesn't.
It fundamentally it suggests the
2022 invasion wasn't an eruption
out of nowhere, but an
escalation of an existing bloody
conflict.
It forces you to redefine
provocation.
Which leads us to how Russia
itself is portrayed.
The source mentions books like
Provoked, which apparently got
slammed for being Kremlin
property propaganda.
Yes, but the author argues the
discomfort with such books isn't
because they invent things, but
because they repeat things.
Repeat what?
Ken and foresaw, what Burns
warned, what Putin said in
Munich, and what Newland
revealed on tape.
It's presented as a reminder of
inconvenient, ignored facts, not
some new revelation.
The author says they saw enough
themselves, studied enough, to
know these warnings were real,
and ignoring them is dishonest.
And this connects to the
contradictory ways Putin is
depicted.
Exactly.
The source calls the Western
narrative almost absurd in its
contradictions.
Is he a weak man dying of stage
6 cancer?
Or is he Hitler reborn, ready to
conquer Europe?
Right.
Is he Trump's lap dog?
Or the master puppeteer behind
Trump.
The source just asked which is
it?
How can he be all these opposing
things simultaneously?
It suggests the portrayal is an
analysis.
It's caricature.
And does that extend to Russia
as a whole, the paper tiger
versus existential threat idea?
Yes, the source highlights that
contradiction to Russia is
derided as a paper tiger with an
economy smaller than Italy's but
also painted as an existential
threat to global democracy.
So weak, but also terrifyingly
strong.
It doesn't add up, the source
argues, and they point to open
source intelligence from the war
itself, all the documented
losses, the drone footage.
What does that show according to
the source?
That Russia is not the
unstoppable juggernaut of
Western nightmares.
They fought with brute
attrition, not blitzkrieg, A
grinding war, not a lightning
conquest.
And their goal isn't world
domination.
The source concludes Russia's
ambition quote is not to roll to
the Atlantic but to hold the
line in the Donbas and to stop
NATO from planning itself on its
border, a more limited defensive
aim in their analysis.
To understand Russia's mindset,
the author includes some really
personal stories.
Right, but the post Soviet
years?
Yes, very powerful ones.
They were called flying over the
Soviet Union in 1990, seeing
fields littered with the
carcasses of dead plains, the
hollowed out relics of a
military industrial empire just
ruined.
A visual of collapse.
Exactly and then being in Saint
Petersburg in 96 the Hermitage
Museum guarded by Mafiosi Nevsky
Prospect, the Main St.
Glittering but everywhere else
scaffolding banner saying things
like restored with funds from
the European Union or funded by
the government of Japan.
Rebuilding national treasures
with foreign money.
The source really emphasizes the
humiliation of that.
Deeply, they ask you to imagine
the humiliation and say America
would never tolerate such public
dependency.
Yet Russia dead because it had
no choice.
So that period of weakness and
humiliation is crucial context
for leader actions.
That's the strong implication, a
drive to regain dignity,
independence after feeling
subjugated.
And what about the whole energy
weapon narrative?
Russia constantly threatening to
turn off the gas.
The source actually counters
that quite strongly.
They argue that Russia rarely
turned off the tab, even when
insulted, even when punished
with the sanctions.
Really.
Even during tense periods.
The author recalls living in
Germany in the 2000s amidst
sanctions and harsh rhetoric,
yet the gas kept flowing.
It suggests more reliability
than often portrayed.
And the contrast is with.
With the US being eager to cut
off Nord Stream and when the
pipelines blew up in 2022, the
source notes, Western
commentators all but cheered,
despite no clear proof of who
did it.
So the conclusion there is what?
The truth is awkward.
Russia showed continuity.
The Wasp showed sabotage, a
direct flip of the usual
narrative about who weaponized
energy.
This reassessment of Russia then
leads to looking critically at
Ukraine's role in all this.
Yes, and the source uses a
really striking metaphor here.
The Dorian Gray one explain
that.
Right, like Oscar Wilde's
character, whose portrait aged
and showed his sins while he
stayed young, the source
suggests Ukraine became the
West's Dorian Gray, that it
absorbed the corruption, The
Dirty work, the secrets the West
wanted kept out of sight.
So Ukraine became a place to
park uncomfortable activities.
That's the implication.
The source lists examples of
this exported rot, as they call
it.
Like what?
Well, they bring up the Biden
family and Burisma again framing
it in this context.
They mentioned tech Bros turn
Kiev into a cheap back office
for Silicon Valley.
Exploding cheaper labor, maybe
looser regulations?
Essentially.
And that hackers and programmers
turned Ukraine into a cyber Gray
zone, a place for activities
maybe not permissible elsewhere.
And there are more serious
allegations to.
Yes, the source claims US linked
labs study pathogens and
facilities that would never pass
political muster in Maryland or
Virginia conducting risky
research away from US oversight.
And even CIA black sites.
They claim the CIA parked black
sites there when it needed legal
limbo, using Ukraine to bypass
legal constraints.
So why Ukraine?
What made it valuable to
Washington, according to this
source?
It wasn't just a pawn, the
source says.
Ukraine has wheat minerals.
Genius programmers and a kind of
entrepreneurial hustle rare in
Europe.
Real assets.
It's a tangible value.
Exactly which leads to the
author's core claim about this
relationship.
Which is precisely why
Washington needed it.
America stayed clean by
exporting its rot.
Ukraine bore the stains.
That's a pretty damning
assessment of the dynamic.
It is, It suggests a very
calculated transactional use of
Ukraine beyond just supporting
democracy.
And this critique broadens out
into US foreign policy
generally.
The author talks about the
personal cost of even
questioning the mainstream
narrative back in 2022.
Yes, very personally about being
harangued, called a stooge a bot
of Benedict Arnold just for
questioning the unprovoked war
line when every Twitter bio flew
the Ukrainian flag.
A real pressure cooker of
conformity.
Total conformity, they say.
And while the hysteria has
cooled, now, maybe shifted to
Gaza, they say, I will not
forget how total the conformity
once was.
It clearly left a mark.
And this experience leads to a
bigger point about.
About what the author calls the
cycle of manufactured
adversaries.
That's what really unsettles
them more than Russia itself.
Manufactured adversaries.
Like how every 18 months the
United States hands the public a
new Emmanuel Goldstein, the
perpetual enemy figure from
Orwell's 1984.
A rotating villain.
Exactly.
Putin, She, Khamenei.
Assad.
Gaddafi.
Saddam.
Noriega.
Ortega.
The names change.
Iran was the threat, then ISIS
now Putin endlessly tomorrow
maybe someone else.
And the point isn't consistency.
The source argues the point is
perpetual outrage, keeping the
public angry, maybe justifying
constant intervention rather
than addressing real, consistent
threats.
And while this cycle is
happening, what's shifting on
the world stage?
A huge shift, the source argues.
What has emerged in the meantime
is a multipolar world the West
pretended could never exist.
The unipolar moment is over.
And the evidence for that.
Bricks, mainly.
What was once the Goldman Sachs
acronym is now a block, with
Russia, China, India, Brazil,
Saudi Arabia and more aligning
outside the dollar.
So more than just an economic
label, now a real geopolitical
force.
That's the argument.
And while Western economists
might sneer at their GDP's, The
Source stresses that commodities
and energy matter more than
spreadsheets.
Real resources, real power.
Like Saudi Arabia and China
trading oil outside the dollar.
Exactly.
Yeah, the source says.
When that happens, the global
order shifts.
It challenges the dollar's
dominance, the foundation of the
Western financial system.
It's a fundamental rebalance.
The punch line, according to the
source, is the irony of how this
came about.
Yes, the conclusion is that the
very outcome Washington feared,
Moscow and Beijing aligned, has
been hastened by Washington's
arrogance.
So Western actions actually
pushed them together.
Paradoxically, yes.
That's the sources final take on
the unintended consequences of
ignoring warnings and insisting
on a unipolar world.
It brings all these threads
together.
So wrapping this all up, where
does the source leave us?
It's not saying Putin is
blameless, right?
Absolutely not.
The author is explicit.
This makes Putin a St. or Russia
an innocent.
They acknowledge Russia uses
espionage, manipulation and
brutality.
That assets remain in the West.
That's a given.
But the author insists none of
that erases the West
provocations.
The core message, repeated
forcefully, is the Western
narrative is a lie because the
war was not unprovoked.
It was cultivated, warned
against, and made inevitable by
decades of provocation.
That's the central thesis.
OK, so let's quickly recap the
key provocations highlighted in
this deep dive, according to the
source.
Ignoring Kennon Burns Putin on
NATO's red lines meddling in
Kiev in 2014, the Newland call,
the funding shaping the
political shift and arming one
side of a civil war in the
Donbas that killed 14,000 people
before 2022 even started.
All leading, the author argues,
to this Western fairy tale about
democracy under siege, which
ignores all that prior history,
that blood already spilled.
And the author expects pushback
expects to be called names.
Yes, they basically say if the
only rebuttal is to call me
naive, an appeaser, A stooge, so
be it.
Call me Chamberlain if you like,
Defiant.
That sticks to the conclusion.
Sticks to it firmly.
History is what it is.
And history in this view shows
this war was not unprovoked.
It was provoked, cultivated, and
foreseen.
That leaves us with a really
challenging final thought from
the source.
The West lit the fuse in
Europe's most dangerous powder
keg, and now the world lives
with the fire.
It really makes you wonder,
doesn't it?
How much of current conflict is
the result of history we haven't
fully acknowledged?
How much is blowback from past
actions ignored warnings?
Thinking about that might change
how you see not just this
conflict, but maybe the next one
too.
Definitely something to chew on.